aider les oiseaux tout en s'aidant
soi-même dans la région de lobinière des
personnes aux prises avec des enjeux de
santé mentale fabriquent des nichoirs
pour des populations d'oiseaux dans le
déclin est parfois alarmant un défi
inspirant relevé par un groupe
d'entraide
[Musique]
des gens qui fréquentent notre ressource
viennent s'impliquer de façon je dirais
pour briser l'isolement je dirais un
prétexte un médium de travail pour que
les gens puissent s'accomplir
[Musique]
et en plus ça l'a plein de bienfaits
pour l'environnement de notre région
comment contribuer à redonner un abri à
des oiseaux champagne et du même coup
permettre à des gens vivant avec des
défis de santé mentale de devenir ou
redevenir des acteurs de changement
[Musique]
je suis éducatrice spécialisée et j'ai
aussi une formation en écologie
appliquée en jumelant ces deux passions
et dites Lambert à lancer un projet pour
accompagner dans l'action les personnes
qui bénéficient des services de
l'organisme d'entraide quelle dirige et
j'habite seul face à ça de mon de mon
isolement ça sort de apprendre à
travailler à prendre à connaître les
gens apprendre à communiquer mais c'est
à moi était à socialiser puis à me
performer pas avancer moi
je viens ici puis
la maison loisir j'aime beaucoup j'aime
les gens ici sont très gentils
c'est pour eux que l'écologiste de
formation a converti le garage de
l'établissement en atelier de travail
pour la fabrication de nichoirs quand
j'ai proposé l'idée au début le monde
n'était pas certain mais finalement tout
le monde embarqué puis on est rendu à
plus de 1000 nichoirs de distribués dans
notre émercé
[Musique]
une installation sur des sujets si
jamais vous avez des questions vous avez
juste à nous rappeler parfait merci
beaucoup bonne journée
on a commandé au-delà de 200 nichoirs
puis depuis ce temps là on commence à
revoir une recrudescence des mères le
bleu ils hirondelles bicolore on
commence à les voir revenir
tranquillement
qu'on s'occupe un peu d'écologie mais en
même temps de l'implication citoyenne de
réinsertion sociale vraiment ça comble
tous les volets
au fur et à mesure qu'il y a des niveaux
quartiers résidantiels
on les installe principalement près des
bassins de rétention comme ici au parc
là où est-ce que il y a un milieu qui se
crée milieu naturel une biodiversité qui
se développe pour s'assurer que les
hirondelles reviennent année après année
justement est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ça fait une différence
ouais je suis persuadé que ça fait une
différence puis je vous disais que je
l'ai expérimenté personnellement et tout
de suite après quelques jours après
l'avoir installé là je voyais des
hirondelles qui tournaient autour du
nichoir donc j'ai la preuve tangible que
ça fonctionne vraiment les gens sont
surpris de voir ah ça marche vraiment
il y a des gens qui qui nous écrivent
qui nous en demandent clairement que ça
doit faire une différence les
oiseaux champêtres des champs c'est
vraiment des espèces qui sont je dirais
plus en déclin de façon générale
[Musique]
donc il faut leur donner un coup de main
en leur offrant justement des nichoirs
adaptés à leurs besoins
depuis presque 5 décennies au Québec
d'hirondelles bicolores a subi une
baisse de près de la moitié de sa
population
c'est que l'agriculture intensive et les
pesticides dessine les populations
d'insectes leur nourriture principale
quant aux merles bleus de l'Est il est
revenu en grand nombre grâce entre
autres à l'installation massive de
nichoir une solution qui a fait ses
preuves pour relancer la nidification de
l'espèce
d'avoir les oiseaux chez soi faire le
même un impact positif sur la santé
mentale des gens je dirais là parce que
c'est le fun d'avoir
[Musique]
puis en plus de dire Coline on a soutenu
une cause la cause de la santé mentale
aussi si on n'est pas des numéros là on
est des personnes en tant que tel puis
c'est pas parce que c'est incendie
mentale que on est on n'est pas informé
de coupe c'est comme si j'arriverai ici
que j'ai été voir comme mes sœurs mes
frères
[Musique]
les membres qui s'impliquent sont fiers
sont contents de ça de cette
contribution là
j'ai beaucoup appris à avoir plus
d'estime de moi-même puis j'aime
beaucoup aussi savoir qu'on aille les
oiseaux
[Musique]